tickets please tickets tickets
all right
all right positive
going through go on
next
oh
negative hey
your boarding position hasn't been
called yet so um why don't you make your
way to the back of the line and i'll
call you later it'll just be a few
hundred milliseconds i promise
next
neutral
oh we don't accept your kind here
go on
get
all right positive
go on through you want me to just head
over there
okay all right thanks
all right next 247
247 come right here
all right
all right make your way this way
okay i'm gonna need you to head past q1
okay you want me to go
back all you have to do is wait right
there and someone's gonna escort you to
your seat all right
okay okay just back there i guess all
right exactly
i'm here i'm gonna need to see your
product ion
um
which which one
um i'm gonna have to see that 32.
uh 32
um that's kind of a private gonna have
to insist
i swear i have it
can you just trust me
all right
i didn't want to have to do this or gone
what's the matter boss i'm gonna need to
see his product ion
go get it you got it boss
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you argon
32.
all right well you see it wasn't so bad
um
so
right this way sir
why didn't you just believe me
uh this is qqq airlines
we just need to be
sure
it's nothing personal